Many forms ask for addresses,
E-commerce in particular.
Incidentally addresses are often
incredibly annoying parts of the form
because they require so
many input fields.
There are street address, postal codes,
territories, countries, region, etc.
But luckily, addresses can be pretty
easily generated from a mobile device.
Essentially all mobile devices have
location services through gps or wi-fi.
By accessing geo location,
you can often auto fill addresses
to within a fairly close range.
Users might need to adjust a bit but
manipulating one input is
obviously better than eight.
For example Uber,
in this example, you could see
how we got the location of the users
with this simple JavaScript code.
Another way to do it will be to
allow users the auto fill option.
Here you could see that with
only few clicks I have been
able to retrieve a location
that was previously saved.
When you search for a car, the app uses
your location to guess your address.
And when you sign up they ask for
permission to use your location.
To learn more about accessing location
services on the web, Android, and
iOS, check out the links
in the instructor notes.